oh we're starting oh how would you
define the job of a product manager well
really your job is to be right but maybe
we can break that down a little bit B
right a lot product management has
become sanction to our approach of
teaching the venture creation
entrepreneurship and innovation here at
Stanford I'm Mike Levin I'm a faculty
member in the School of Engineering here
at Stanford I'd like to welcome you to
this program for which I serve as
academic director so basically involves
setting a clear direction for your team
understanding what it is you need to do
sequencing to get there and doing
everything it takes to get it done I
think an important part of product
management making decisions and it's a
trainable style like it's not magic you
get comfortable making decisions by
making a lot of decisions there's the
reason that a lot of CEOs come out of
product management you get trained on
making lots of decisions really quickly
and then you get better visit
I think what's unique about this course
is we have a combined 20 years of
experience doing this in top Silicon
Valley companies and we're not gonna
give you the theoretical frameworks
we're gonna give you what reality
actually looks like like what is the
day-to-day what do you actually do like
you can sort of imagine an alternate
version of the textbook and this one is
like actually doing so we will feature
the frameworks at the same time we'll
give you a bunch of examples from a
personal experience but also from a lot
of people in the industry that we've
worked with met or have a fortune of
connecting with I learned product
management the hard way through
countless mistakes lots of late nights
that turned into early mornings and a
great deal of wasted time and money
that's why I'm so excited that we're
able to offer this program on product
management so that you can learn
directly from experience product
managers and not have to repeat all the
stakes that I learned so painfully one
of the reasons that we were excited to
make this class is we haven't found any
great resources people on our team
the goal of this class is to really find
a scalable way to say what we wish we
knew and we were getting product
management yes and we've also been
teaching this for three years at
Stanford and we wanted a way for this to
scale beyond just the classroom
hundreds of people apply each year and
we can only give 30 to 40 slots and with
this we want all of you guys to be able
to take it we can't wait to see you
online in our class see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]